what's up everyone i'm back for another
video this time actually recording in
the morning because my roommate is out
of the house and i am more secretive
about this channel than a cheating
spouse
um today we are going to go ahead and
talk about batch processing which means
we're almost to the end of all the stuff
that um designing data intensive
applications talks about and i can move
on to some more you know practical
systems designing concepts using actual
technologies and hopefully that'll be
pretty useful for everyone so let's get
into that
okay batch processing what is it well a
lot of times companies want to do huge
computations on tons of data for example
if they want to build search indexes
do some machine learning data
aggregation or even just recommendations
based on a bunch of data and also etl
processes to put data from you know one
type of data format like in a
transactional database and move it to an
analytical database
however the thing is we've discussed
kind of how companies tend to store tons
of data to do analytics on and generally
speaking that's in something like a data
warehouse however data warehouses are
inherently limiting first of all
you're limited by the sql query language
which means that you can only do things
that sql supports and you can't just run
arbitrary code on your data additionally
it requires that your data has to be
structured which means that you actually
have to pre-format it somehow as opposed
to just dumping a bunch of data
somewhere and then writing code later to
handle it
so this is where something where
distributed file systems and batch
processing come in so what's a
distributed file system well if you can
think of a normal file system on your
local computer which just has
directories subdirectories and files a
distributed file system is the same
thing but running over a bunch of
different computers with some
replication and as a result redundancy
file systems such as hadoop which is the
open source version of basically the
original distributed file system google
file system can be replicated around the
world in order to get some good
performance and distribute it over a
bunch of nodes
okay so what is mapreduce well mapreduce
is also kind of like this open source
batch processing programming model which
works on top of hadoop so in order to
make
computations you basically need to write
two functions a mapper and a reducer
and then you know mapreduce is going to
do the rest for you but just to give a
more you know
in-depth overview of what's actually
happening
you give mapreduce a ton of input files
by specifying some directory in hdfs
and you're just going to go ahead and
return a bunch of output files you never
modify the input files it's immutable
and then those output files can actually
be passed into another mapreduce job
computation is parallelized amongst the
nodes in the hadoop cluster and they
optimize for data locality what that
means is that
you want to actually run the mapper
generally speaking on the nodes where
the input files are located because of
the fact that copying all that data over
the network to another node is very
expensive since there's a ton of data
whereas just copying the code for the
mapping function is much cheaper
another optimization if you can't run
all of that on the original node is to
just run one in the same like server
rack or something or a computer very
close to it to minimize the amount of
data you're moving over the network
additionally it's designed for frequent
faults why is this well originally when
google created mapreduce they were using
it as background tasks on their servers
and oftentimes they would have to
preempt those tasks if they needed more
resources for their production servers
and so if one mapper or reducer job
actually fails it doesn't reset every
mapper reducer job you can just go ahead
and retry that one later
okay continuing on mapreduce so i'm
going to kind of um you know discuss
mapreduce in the context of this image
on the right but as you can see um every
file is broken into a set of records and
so imagine that you know you have a file
on each
node and
that would just kind of be an hdfs
so the file is going to be broken into a
set of records and the mapper function
is going to take each record and extract
a key and value for it and then what
we're going to do is on each node we
have all these keys and values and we're
going to put each key and value into
this partition file which is basically
saying okay all the keys and values that
are going to this reducer node which we
can you know determine via hash function
are going to go on this file all the
ones that are going to the second
reducer node are going to this file etc
etc and then what you're going to do is
take all of those files of keys and
values that are going to a given reducer
node and sort them internally this helps
because then once we pass them to the
reducer node the reducer can go ahead
and basically run a merge algorithm
which is able to easily sort all of
those keys and values together and the
good thing is that when the reducer
has all of the keys and values on its
local copy of the data
all the keys um
basically all the values with the same
key are right next to one another so you
don't have to use a ton of memory
keeping track of like
the individual processing for each key
you could just go through one key at a
time and iterate through all the values
so anyway the reducer function basically
has all of the values for a given key
and it can just go ahead and iterate
over them and do anything you want with
it
okay so i've discussed like very
basically what mapreduce does but there
are also some nuances to this um
oftentimes there are data associations
between files and you know we see this
all the time
and so sometimes what you want to do is
perform joins in mapreduce so there are
basically three types of joins
and those are going to be sword merge
joins broadcast hash joins and partition
task joins basically the general
philosophy behind all this is we want to
reduce the amount of network calls to
you know possibly a second database if
we're joining on a database or something
along those lines or a second data set
so the first one is sort merge joins
this is known as a reduced side join
because the reducer is the one actually
doing the logic of the join but i'll
explain it right here with this diagram
below
so imagine we have two sets of files and
we want to combine them to basically go
ahead and merge them together where the
key is the same so we have mappers now
on both sets of files
and then using a hash function we'll
send
the records with the same key to the
same reducer and the reducer will go
ahead and merge them so as you can see
imagine i have all this browser data for
myself as you can see that's what a
typical day of browsing looks like for
me we also have my age in there and so
what's going to happen is as a result of
the partitioning and hash function
they're going to get sent to the same
reducer which will go ahead and combine
them so it's going to attach that h data
to every single piece of browser data
next we have broadcast hash joins so
imagine the same situation as before but
you know let's say that all of the user
data for age
there was enough or there was so little
of that data that it could actually all
fit in an in-memory hashmap on
all of the mappers for the browser data
so what that means is that since it can
all fit in an in-memory hashmap we don't
even have to use a second mapper and you
know pass it to the reducer what we can
do is just load that whole data set into
memory on all of the mappers and then go
ahead and perform the join on the mapper
instead
okay so that's what happens when one of
the data sets is super small
and then there's also this concept of
partition hash joins which is really
similar to the broadcast hash join
however
if one of the if neither of the two data
sets is small enough to completely fit
in memory but they're partitioned the
same way we can basically just only load
the relevant partition of the smaller
data set into memory on the mapper so
what that means is like
say i have all the files for both the
age data and the browsing data
and their partitions such that like
there's one file that contains all the a
names one file that contains all the b
names the cnames and that's the case for
both age and browsing history then we
can actually just make it so that you
know when you have all those mappers for
the browsing history and say we're doing
the mappings for all the a names we can
just go ahead and only load in the a
ages into memory
so that's also known as a map side join
because the mapper is doing the logic
okay anyways pitfalls of mapreduce thus
far i've described mapreduce as kind of
like this perfect really simplistic
programming model in order to go ahead
and make huge batch computations and you
know for a while it was really widely
used people like um google were using it
all the time but now it's less popular
and i'll explain why
well first of all when chaining these
jobs together
one needs to wait for the preceding one
to completely finish in order to start
executing so that's bad for a multitude
of reasons the first one is that there
might be stragglers certain map or
reduced jobs might take a really long
time and even though the subsequent map
reduced job could you know partially get
started it feels the need to completely
wait for these stragglers in order to
get started which is very bad for
throughput
additionally we waste a ton of disk io
which means we're doing a ton of writes
to disk for this concept of intermediate
state intermediate state is basically
saying imagine we have two mapreduce
jobs chained together but the result of
the first one we really don't care about
we're never going to use it for anyone
else
it's solely just like an intermediate
computation
mapreduce is going to write that all out
to disk which is pretty useless and
takes a ton of time so mapreduce
materializes this intermediate state
which is not always necessary
and then finally since mapreduce
contains a mapper per reduce we're
always going to end up sorting those
keys and oftentimes that's not necessary
either a lot of times you just want to
you know sort one time and then
subsequently the data can already be
sorted in the way you want you don't
need to do it again
okay so this leads us to the more modern
day solution which most companies are
using which are dataflow engines so if
you've ever heard of apache spark that's
what this is so what they do is instead
of just having specific mappers and
reducers they'll chain a bunch of
functions together called operators so
again that reduces the need for
unnecessary mappers and so what this
does is it's much more transparent about
the entire flow of data as opposed to
just seeing a mapper and reducer as a
black box
it goes ahead and
maps out all of the data dependencies so
it can optimize for those and be as fast
as possible
that allows us to do better with data
locality
obviously it
does parallel computations in the same
way that mapreduce does meaning that you
know each node in the cluster is doing
as much computation as it can
and another big thing is that it doesn't
materialize intermediate state so what
that means is that it's a little bit
less fault tolerant than mapreduce
because if things are kept in memory and
one of the nodes crashes well you kind
of have to somehow get that state back
so what it tends to do is there will be
occasional checkpoints in the flow of
the computation you know you write
something to disk and then you know if
you crash and you're a little bit
screwed you just have to go a bit back
in time and redo the calculations that
you've lost
but ultimately this tends to make for
better performance on the whole assuming
there aren't too many crashes
another thing is that means that all
functions have to be deterministic
because if you're retrying something
obviously you want the same result as
before there can't be like any you know
time related stuff when things are
executed
okay so in conclusion for batch
processing
batch processing is super useful for
companies because they can basically
just dump a ton of data into a
distributed file system in an
unformatted way and then eventually a
bunch of different teams can go ahead
and take those
immutable files and work on them in any
way that they basically want
even though
mapreduce was kind of the original
solution to do batch processing
spark has come around and it's really
optimized on that a lot because you know
kind of thinking about the entire
movement and transitioning of the data
is going to allow you to optimize the
performance of the entire workload a lot
more
and then even though batch processing
basically happens on a bound set of data
we know the input files before we start
our batch job there's something called
stream processing that allows doing
computations on data as it comes in and
that'll probably be the topic of my next
video
alright so we're making a ton of
progress guys
i'll see you in the next one